[Music]
have you ever gotten into an
argument that you just couldn't win did
it feel like the other person was using
some
deceptive tactics to try to persuade you
well there's a good chance that they
were using logical fallacies
whether they knew it or not hi i'm rich
burnett for
one dream and in this episode of
perspectives
a handful of experts will show you how
to identify logical fallacies
and how to argue against them we start
off with a general
overview of what a fallacy is and then
we discuss a thought experiment that
asks
what's more likely to kill you your dog
or your couch
enjoy
[Music]
a logical fallacy is a flaw in reasoning
that leads to a faulty conclusion
logical fallacies often appear
reasonable on the surface sometimes
they're true errors in thinking
but when used in a prepared speech
they're usually
deliberate attempts to mislead or
manipulate the audience
in that situation they're designed to
make the audience
think that the speaker's logic is sound
but in fact
the speaker is muddying the logic or
misusing pathos through baseless
emotional appeals it is not terribly
important that you remember the names
of each of these fallacies and let you
want to trot them out to impress your
friends
but it is worthwhile to be able to
notice
what a conclusion does not logically
follow and to be able to say
why law students spend three years
learning how to do this
being able to do this makes them into
better lawyers
and if you can do it too you will be
a more persuasive speaker
let's turn to another category of
logical fallacies
and to do this let me ask you a question
which do you
think is more likely to kill you your
dog
or your couch and when i ask my
law students this they say their couch
because they figure this must be a trick
question
instinct tells most of us that the dog
is more dangerous but my law students
are right to be suspicious data shows
that you're 30 times more likely
to die from falling off furniture in
your own house than you are to be killed
by a dog
the point is though most of us are going
to answer this question based on how
quickly examples spring into our minds
maybe we second guess that impulse like
my law students do
but for most humans it feels right that
an event is more probable
if examples come to mind quickly and
easily
that is a logical fallacy called the
availability heuristic
the availability heuristic operates on
the notion that
if something springs to mind easily it
must be
important or at least more important
than alternatives that are not as
readily recalled
people are unreasonably afraid of
astronomically rare shark attacks
because of the availability heuristic
the reality is
you should be more afraid of almost
anything
than you are of sharks because almost
anything
is more likely to kill you than a shark
is
here are a few list of things that
according to official death statistics
kill more people every year than sharks
in no particular order
ready obesity texting
lightning hippos airplanes
deer icicles hot dogs volcanoes
falling out of bed bathtubs shopping on
black friday
dogs ants jellyfish tornadoes playing
high school football
roller coasters and vending machines
on a more serious note surveys indicate
that americans feel less safe now than
they have in the past
in 2015 a pew research center survey
asked americans if gun violence in the
country had increased
decreased or stayed the same over the
previous 20 years since the mid-90s
more than half of participants said that
gun crimes had increased
another 26 percent said that gun
violence had stayed the same
both of these groups were wrong and not
by a little bit
in point of fact gun violence in the u.s
had dropped by
half the gun homicide rate went from
7 in 100 000 in 1993
to 3.6 in 100 000 in 2010
but not only were the people surveyed
not aware of these improvements
many people half of them drew
exactly the wrong conclusion about the
state of violent crime in the u.s
why well the availability heuristic is
one reason
given the way violent incidents are
reported in the internet age
immediately repeatedly and vividly
people naturally think that these events
are
more likely than they actually are
the availability heuristic can lead us
to make all kinds of sub-optimal
decisions
from purchasing too much insurance to
not allowing our kids to play
unsupervised
another logical fallacy that operates
similarly to the availability heuristic
is confirmation bias confirmation bias
is the tendency to look for things that
confirm what you already believe
and to disregard everything else it's
similar to the availability heuristic
and that it's making your own
pre-existing beliefs paramount you want
your belief to be true
so you look for evidence that confirms
that idea and either
ignore other evidence or stop gathering
additional evidence the confirmation
bias captures the fact that your beliefs
and opinions are based on cherry-picked
data
years or even decades of situations in
which evidence that confirms them
grabbed your attention while
disconfirming evidence was ignored
it's why sometimes when you learn a new
fact or become engrossed in some topic
elements of that theme seem to follow
you everywhere
you get excited about electric cars for
instance and
only then do you notice all the charging
stations on your way to work that you
hadn't seen before
or if you're a woman trying to get
pregnant you see babies and other
pregnant women everywhere and you wonder
if the world really is becoming
overpopulated
the confirmation bias is especially
rampant in political debates
where candidates cherry-pick data points
to support their policies
rather than creating policies based on
all the data
the climate science debate will go down
in history as a prime example
for every new study demonstrating the
link between human activity
and climate change deniers point to one
data point or two
showing that parts of the earth are
cooler now than in the past
for example more snow in winter on the
east coast is used by climate change
deniers as proof that the earth
is cooling while in fact scientists know
that the increased precipitation
is a predicted effect of warming ocean
currents
rather than looking at all the data and
trying to understand
how counter-intuitive effects can result
from global warming
deniers grab hold of bits of information
that on the surface
seem to confirm their opinion part of
the reason that these types of fallacies
can be so difficult to debate is because
they are based on research
sometimes there are flaws in the
research itself but most of the time
it's when people move from evidence to
extrapolation
that they start to use argument
fallacies there is a lot
of evidence that there have been harsh
winters in recent years
this is a quantifiable claim that we can
all research
we can compare precipitation rates and
temperatures
to show that when winter arrives it can
be a very nasty season
that is evidence that very few people
could disagree with and very few
scientists would say is flawed
so far so good the problem is when we
take that evidence and then
draw out an implication that says that
global warming must be a hoax
because look outside how cold it is look
us
outside at how much snow there is on the
ground that move to try to use the
evidence to support the claim
that global warming is a hoax is where
the fallacy kicks in
climate change does not mean that all of
the earth
loses all of its seasons and just turns
into one hot planet for everyone
so how does a skilled debater counter
these persuasive fallacies
it is not enough to point out that they
represent a flaw
in reasoning or logic in my experience
you have to attack one of them based on
what makes them persuasive
while simultaneously presenting your own
evidence that can bask the general claim
they are defending arguing against
slippery slope fallacies is extremely
difficult
why because slippery slope fallacies use
fear to motivate the audience to imagine
the worst case scenarios rather than use
empirical data or expert opinion
to make reasoned judgments the only way
to beat the slippery slope fallacy
is to point it out and then to break the
presumed sequence of events
needed to establish the worst case
scenario in the case of the bathroom
predator myth
it is extremely hard to do because of
the fearful image of a predator dressing
up as a woman and sneaking into a
bathroom
the power of this fallacy cannot be
understated
it is extremely difficult to conquer
fears
such as this and move the audience
towards a more reasoned understanding of
the issue
tap into people's fears with a slippery
slope fallacy
and the other side has a huge task to
identify the fallacy and debunk it
a corollary to the slippery slope
fallacy is the false dilemma
a false dilemma occurs when a person
argues that there are only two choices
available to the audience
when there may in fact be more than just
two options available to them
by describing an issue as an either or
proposition
they limit the range of arguments
available and create a false binary
the context of the debate over bathroom
use legislation
we find one major false dilemma
proponents of limiting bathroom use
according to the birth certificate
gender identification
created a binary between protecting
transgender people
and protecting innocent women
what was lost in the public debates was
any discussion of doing something to
prevent predators from attacking people
in the first place
there was an acceptance on the part of
the opponents of the protections for
transgender people
that predators exist and are waiting for
the green light to start attacking women
in bathrooms
instead of figuring out what motivates
predators and talking about ways to help
prevent and catch them the assumption
was that predators were inevitable
and therefore the audience had to choose
between protecting this group
transgender people or that group women
using public bathrooms
of course this is not the only
fallacious line of reasoning people
embrace
consider for example when two things are
correlated when they
happen at the same time or one right
before the other
what do we conclude that one causes the
other right
yet such reasoning is often fallacious
correlation
does not entail causation night always
comes before day
but night doesn't cause day both are the
effects of the earth's rotation the rate
of violent crime
always increases when ice cream sales
increase
but ice cream does not cause or induce
violence
the correlation is simply due to a
common third factor both
spike in the summer such reasoning can
even be dangerous
for example autism has been diagnosed in
some children
shortly after they received the measles
mumps and rubella vaccine
but that doesn't mean that vaccines
cause autism
it's simply the case that the age at
which children's immune system
are developed enough to receive the
vaccine well that's around the same time
that diagnosable signs of autism
begin to appear yet people have still
concluded that vaccines are to blame
and have stopped vaccinating their
children consequently
many preventable diseases that were once
all but eradicated
are on the rise again such people are
so convinced that nothing seems to be
able to dissuade them
not only have studies claiming the link
been discredited
and not only have autism rates continued
to rise
despite the fact that the suspected
culprit thimerosal
was removed from the vaccine and not
only have studied showed
that the rates of autism are the same
among vaccinated and unvaccinated
children
but doctors can often detect signs of
autism before the administration of the
mmr vaccine
what more proof do you need and yet
would you point all this
out some people will still just say but
i know someone who got vaccinated
and then was diagnosed with autism again
correlation does not entail causation i
know someone who put on a shirt
and then was hit by a car that doesn't
mean anything
a correlation between two things might
maybe
be a reason to investigate whether there
is a causal link between them
but once the investigation is done if
you don't find a link
that's it game over should we trust
reason
honestly most of the time we shouldn't
trust
instinctive reasoning it's just not that
reliable
it occasionally gets things right but it
always needs to be checked by
careful reasoning which can in general
be trusted it in fact is responsible for
our advancement
as a species that's not to say that it's
perfect
even the most careful reasoning can get
things wrong
but it doesn't have to be perfect to be
trustworthy
we should never forget however that it
can still go wrong
this is why you always want to check
your careful reasoning for flaws
make sure that no fallacious instinctive
reasoning slipped in
try to find errors even look for
evidence that you're wrong after all
how hard is it to confirm your beliefs
if that's all you're trying to do
anyone can find some evidence for
anything
if you want to prove yourself right try
to prove yourself
wrong because if you try to prove
yourself wrong and can't
it's a really good indication that
you're right want to be even more
assured
invite others to prove you wrong and
remember
admit it when you are wrong
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about any of the topics in
this episode
the full list of series that these clips
came from is in the description below
you can watch all the full series now on
onedream.com
and don't forget to subscribe to this
youtube channel turn on notifications
and you'll get an alert every time we
post a new episode of perspectives